what i want to start thinking about in
this videos are ways for molecules to go
across a cellular membrane either from
the outside to the inside or from the
inside to the outside and the first type
of transport of molecule across
membranes that i'm going to talk about
are is transport that does not require
energy it's it's all about it's all
about molecules moving down their
concentration gradient and that type of
transport we call passive transport
passive transport so it does not require
energy
it's really just about things moving
down their concentration gradient so
down
let me write move down concentration
gradient
move
down
concentration
concentration
gradient
now if you have this cellular membrane a
lot of things might want to move down
their concentration gradient but this
membrane is selectively permeable it's
going to be more or less permeable to
different types of molecules so let's
think about these different types of
molecules and think about how they might
diffuse passively across the membrane
so if we have really small molecules we
can say okay they might be able to fit
in the gaps between the
the hydrophilic heads and maybe they
might not be and they might be able to
fit between the gaps of the hydrophobic
tails and get through so being small is
good so small
if you're small that aids transport
passive transport aids diffusion across
the membrane and in particular it really
helps to be small and non-charged
small and no
and no charge so examples of that could
be things like carbon dioxide
so
carbon dioxide
it's a small molecule it doesn't have a
charge so carbon dioxide molecules if i
have a higher concentration on the
outside on the outside actually let me
do the other way around let's see i have
a higher concentration on the inside
than i have on
the outside
well just as we learned in the diffusion
video in a given amount of time you're
going to have more carbon dioxide
molecules interacting with the bottom
going from the going from inside of the
cell and interacting with the membrane
then from the outside of the cell
and
sure they don't have any charge and so
they're not going to be particularly
attracted to the hydrophilic head of our
phospholipids but they're also not going
to be repelled by them and they're going
to have more on the inside interacting
with the membrane than the outside and
so since they're small some of them are
going to be able to pass through and
they're also not going to be bothered by
the hydrophobic tails and they're going
to have things going both ways but
you're going to have more going from the
inside to the outside than from the
outside to the inside so they're going
to move along with their concentration
gradient so carbon dioxide can actually
diffuse quite well across cellular
membranes another molecule that can is
molecular oxygen
molecular oxygen can also diffuse quite
well across cellular membranes so if i
have a higher concentration of out of
oxygen on the outside than i have on the
inside because it's small and it's
non-charged it's not going to have
problems you know it's not going to be
particularly attracted to the
hydrophilic heads but they're small
they're going to be able to pass right
between them it's going to be
indifferent to them and then it's going
to be able to pass through all these
hydrophobic tails and since you have a
higher concentration on the outside than
the inside you're just going to have
more in a given amount of time more
random interactions of the ones going in
that direction than the ones going in
that direction so you would have a net
inflow into the cells so these things
are going to be able to diffuse fairly
fairly whoops these things are going to
be able to diffuse fairly fairly
naturally now and of course they are
going to be obstructed by by just the
structure by all of these molecules here
that make up the actual cellular
membrane but they're going to be able to
get through
now what about things that would have a
lot of trouble getting through so things
that would have a lot of trouble getting
through would be things like
like a sodium ion
a sodium ion or a potassium
or a
potassium ion
why would they have trouble getting
through well let's just imagine let's
say i have a higher concentration of
sodium on the outside
on the outside than i have on the inside
well they might be attracted to the
hydrophilic heads here that have some
charge
but there's no reason why they would
then want to go any further they'll be
they're going to be attracted to the
hydrophilic heads that have charge and
they're going to they're not going to
and the hydrophobic tails have nothing
nothing interesting for them they're
going to want to they're going to want
to maybe clump around the the
phosphate heads but not be able to
migrate all the way through so things
that have outright charge are going to
have trouble just passively diffusing
we'll see in future videos that there's
other ways for them to get through you
have things like channel proteins which
essentially give them tunnels and we'll
talk more about that but just naturally
the fusion natural diffusion is going to
be hard for things like this
now what about things that are in
between what about things like water
molecules and water is incredibly
important because cells are living in an
aqueous environment they're surrounded
by water on the inside of the cell and
the outside of the cell and water is in
between because it's not doesn't have an
outright charge but it has a partially
water molecules oxygen two hydrogens
oxygen likes to hog the electrons has a
partial negative charge on that end the
hydrogens have their electrons charged
have partial positive and
a partial positive charge on that end
and we call these phosphate heads
hydrophilic because they're attracted to
water and water is attracted to it so
the water molecules the water molecules
for sure are going to be attracted are
going to be attracted to the hydrophilic
heads
but their charge isn't so strong it
isn't so strong that they can't if if we
have enough interactions a lot of them
will be attracted but some of them will
actually make it through the water
molecule is small enough and it's and
its charge is not strong enough i guess
you could say it has some polarity but
it's going to be able to make it through
not as easily as the carbon dioxide or
the molecular oxygen but it can it will
be able to slowly diffuse through and as
we'll see there's other ways that this
can be facilitated by where the water
can go through once again these we'll
see in future videos things like
aquaporins the tunnels through
through the membrane so it doesn't have
to deal with all of this business right
over here and of course if you have
really large molecules if you had like a
big if you had a big honking protein
right over here this would have trouble
this would have trouble it would have
trouble even physically getting through
the gaps not to mention whether parts of
it are hydrophobic or hydrophilic so
hopefully this gets you a sense of the
types of things that can diffuse through
a cellular membrane this is a form of
passive trans transport and in the in
the in the next video we'll talk about
facilitated passive transport